- Whatever happened to your
favorite foods from childhood?
- [Vaughn] You got your
Dunkaroos, WWE Bars.
- Hi-C Ecto Coolers.
- Essentially, our entire
childhood has been discontinued.
Do you miss those iconic
foods from childhood
that you just can't seem to track down?
- [Brenda] Well, we're here
to fix that, I'm Brenda.
- [Vaugn] And I'm Vaughn.
- [Brenda] We're tasty producers
that miss our childhoods.
- [Vaugn] And we're on a mission
to track down these forgotten recipes,
recreate them from scratch,
and bring it back now ya'll.
- [Both] So, let's
explore the Discontinued.
- Mine was the Nestle Wonder Ball.
- You know what, that's something
that today's kids will just never know.
- I think that we should try to figure out
what happened to the Wonder Ball.
And then, see if we can get
our hands on one and make one?
- Make one?
- You get on the computer,
I'll get on the phone.
Let's do this.
(toy phone ringing)
Hello, candy police, mhm, this is he.
- [Brenda] What?
- Okay, Brenda, it came
out as the Magic Ball,
a chocolate sphere with
a toy inside of it,
but there was an FDA rule that said
you can't combine candy with toys.
This is why we cannot have nice things.
Essentially, it got
discontinued and then...
- It was brought back, check this out.
Inside, there was freaking
candy, no longer toys.
- I remember when I was
a young girl trying to...
(bleep)
What would happen if we tried
to get one here from another country?
- [Brenda] Oh, forget it.
That's illegal
- [Vaughn] It's illegal?
- Do you know how much you're
going to be fined with?
$2,500, Vaughn, right there,
it says it right there.
Okay, so, this is the
deal, we can no longer
have chocolate with toys.
- Right.
- So, guess what man?
We gonna have to make it.
- We're gonna have to make it!
- Let's do it!
- Okay.
How are we gonna do it?
(laughs)
What makes up the ball, it's
literally just chocolate.
- Toy.
- That's it.
Unbelievable.
- The more you know.
Wait, what kind of chocolate
are we gonna use, though?
- We gonna need someone
who's super familiar with that taste.
(gasps)
- Betsy.
- You guys have got to be kidding me.
This is like my childhood
in every shape or form.
This is so cool.
- So, this is a table cloth.
- I feel so defenseless.
- We know you're a Wonder
Ball, 90s enthusiast.
We want you to pick the chocolate
that most closely resembles
that of the childhood favorite.
- I'm ready for this.
- Yes, queen.
- [Betsy] Okay.
Oh yeah, that's good.
- That one's good?
- [Brenda] Alright, girl,
keep stuffing yourself.
- Okay.
- That's okay?
Now, chocolate number three.
- Oh yeah, no, no, hands
down, the first one.
When I think of, like,
the Nestle Wonder Ball,
I think of milk chocolate.
- Right.
- And this is definitely a milk chocolate.
- We can 100 percent do this.
- I believe in you guys.
- You believe in us, Betsy?
- Yeah, I mean, you
have to do this for me.
I'm counting on you to bring back
literally an edible piece of my childhood.
- [Vaughn] Alright.
- Okay, that's enough.
- Get out of here.
Get out of here, we got a a job a to do.
- Wait, can I take on these though?
- No!
- Are Serious?
- She took our Etch-A-Sketch.
Alright, I've got these.
- That's really good.
- Let's get going, shall we?
(electronic music)
We want this to be as easy as possible.
So, literally just chips in the
bowl, microwave, stir, pour.
- Microwave is the way.
- [Vaughn] I'll be right back.
- [Brenda] Alright.
- [Vaughn] We gonna just
whip this guy in here,
stir it around a little bit.
So, I think, for this one, we should do
the Alvin magic chocolate ball.
(electronic music)
I don't really know how to do
that, but well figure it out.
So, we've got this guy.
- Yeah.
(electronic music)
Alright, so, close 'em.
- Let's do this.
(electronic music)
Okay.
- And go around.
- [Vaughn] Alright, okay.
- [Brenda] Okay.
- I think we're pretty good.
- I think it's freezing time.
(electronic music)
- [Vaughn] Okay.
- [Brenda] Okay.
(laughing)
- No!
- At least, we can stuff it with the toy.
(fun, playful music)
- I think what I'm gonna do is just
take a little bit of chocolate in each,
and I'm just gonna kinda swirl it around.
That is thick, momma.
Thick with three C's and
spaces in between the C's.
(laughing)
I'm gonna go freeze these.
So, I'm gonna try to get these out.
I don't know if it's gonna work.
It's still a little too
thin around the edges there.
So, we're gonna have
to work pretty quickly.
- This looks like failure.
(knocking)
- I think that we're gonna have
to reinforce, like, around
here, I think it's fine.
I'm gonna go freeze these.
We're gonna do another layer after that.
It's not super pretty on the inside.
This is like the thick,
double-reinforced ones.
- Okay, I mean, ooh.
(laughing)
(mysterious synths)
- Oh, my god, I cracked it a little bit.
(sighs)
- But that's perfect.
It's still holding on.
- Okay, it's perfect.
I want it to be even perfecter.
(slow whistling instrumental)
- Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
(gasping)
(laughing)
- Let's put a toy in there.
(slow whistling instrumental)
That's amazing.
I think what we need to do to seal it,
is melt, kind of, each half, okay.
(laughing)
Give me a toy!
- There it is.
- Quickly, quickly.
Okay.
- Close it, close it.
- Oh, but I feel like this side needs
to be a little bit melt-y too.
(soft whistling instrumental)
Okay, okay.
- Okay.
- I like this.
I think we can make it even
more magical than this.
It's fine, it's not amazing.
(slow whistling instrumental)
- Right now, she's gonna think
it was like kindergarten work.
- This one looks like it's gonna come out.
Yes.
- So, go about it, maybe
use some extra chocolate
to sort of like a glue, chocolate glue.
Let's go in with the glue
and see what happens,
but I honestly think this is...
- [Vaughn] Okay, good, we
gotta get a toy in there.
Toy, Toy!
- [Brenda] Where was it?
- You can't forget the damn toy!
Oh, that's a cute one,
wow, that's heavy, okay.
(slow whistling instrumental)
Brenda, I think she's beautiful.
Brenda!
(sentimental music)
Betsy needs to see this,
I want her to open it.
Alright, Brenda, who's the
least clumsy out of both of us?
- [Brenda] I just tripped.
I think you should go.
- So, that's me.
Yes, alright.
- Ladies first.
This is it.
- If I drop this,
my life is over.
- It's your fault.
- Wanna see what surprises
hide inside your Wonder Ball?
- Wait, this feels, I've, this is like...
(funky, playful music)
It's making noise, this is so cool.
I'm just gonna crack it open.
It's a good chocolate dinosaur egg.
Oh, cool, what!
(fun, jazzy music)
- It's all yours!
- Oh, my gosh!
Yay!
- [Vaughn] It's a little car.
- [Brenda] You've gotta give it a bite.
- How does it taste?
- This is, like, better than
the Nestle Wonder Balls
that I had as a kid.
- Yes!
- It's a cat-doughnut car.
- Cat-doughnut car!
- Two of my favorite things!
Yay!
- Ooh.
Come on, Brenda, get in here.
- [Brenda] I'm so glad you liked it.
- This is the best Friday ever.
- Aw.
- I think our work here is done.
- I think so.
(sentimental music)